i don't know how many of you remember
wonder egg priority
it was a pretty good show from a season
or two ago that i made a video on
it follows this girl trying to revive
her dead friend and it had really nice
animation wasn't afraid to talk about
suicide which is like a really big
underlying problem in japan
i enjoyed the show very very much it had
a number of strong female leads which
you don't see often
and really cool action with huge weapons
reminiscent of killakil which is an
anime classic for a generation at this
point
but the ending left a little bit to be
desired and by
a little i mean a lot of unresolved
content that even jrr tolkien would have
a hard time fitting into a hundred page
chapter of lord of the rings a lot
but i stayed optimistic because after
the finale a special was announced
almost
immediately that would wrap up the show
and act as the actual finale for the
series
which i was very happy to hear at the
time and so a couple of months passed
and the special
pretty silently made its way onto
websites i almost forgot about it
honestly
and boy was it dog [ __ ] i literally
cannot remember the last time an anime
series had such a poor
excuse for an ending and i've been
watching a lot of moist critical lately
so my soft spoken but incredibly
unfiltered critique and commentary
levels are
off the charts right now so i currently
plan on
rkoing this finale into absolute
oblivion
just like it did to the rest of the show
before it
wonder egg priority's special ending was
an absolute massacre
it was like they took a chapter out of
game of thrones book of terrible finales
and then in some big prank remade it in
an attempt to one-up it and
unironically be even worse and they
succeeded
there was truly not a single redeeming
part of the special that i could find
even from me who thoroughly enjoyed the
original show
i was desperately digging into some deep
part of me to like it as i watched but
i just absolutely could not it was it
was that terrible
and normally i worry about spoilers and
the like for my videos i try not to show
them
but the thing is i don't recommend
anyone watch this series anymore
anything i said before in my video is
null and void
i amend the praise for my previous
wonder egg video
and so today i'm talking about all of it
all the ways that this show went wrong
in the finale
the car crash and fiery explosion as a
result of a gas leak at a gas station
from someone smoking their last
cigarette before they killed themselves
after watching this finale
and even if you haven't seen the show
i'm sure you'll find it amusing
just how horribly it went let's go
so the original show which basically
follows four girls who enter their
dreams to defeat monsters which
eventually leads them to saving their
friends who oft themselves kill
themselves
basically ends with our four girls
getting obliterated by this dream
creation of sorts that seem to be the
reason
causing girls to kill themselves like
they got the yamcha treatment
they're like a little webkin pet friends
who helped them fight monsters got
one tapped and then the creation just
feasted on their flesh
like it was actually really cool and
dramatic in the original show
it was absolutely crazy there was this
awesome backstory behind the creation as
well like almost this
frankenstein-esque tale which again i
really enjoyed
and then this finale came along and god
and essentially after each of the girls
saved their dead best friends after they
fought enough monsters
they got brought back to life yay yippee
and then
the girls got their souls crushed
fighting these monsters or whatever and
lost hope
they quit being little sailor moon girls
because their little pets died
except for our main lead girl who set
herself at the end to like finish her
mission
or whatever and be a warrior of eros and
fight the natos
yeah that is what she said word for word
and i i don't think up to this point
either
eros or the nattos were things we had
ever heard of like she just drew up this
little isekai story premise of hers at
the very end of the show
and and anyway so now we're all caught
up for the special
and then the special which is at surface
a nice 46 minutes a lengthy two episodes
felt kind of promising at first that it
might be able to cover most of that
which was left undone
and then it proceeds to spend what i
just covered in a minute
in the first 25 minutes of the special
over half of the finale is a recap which
was kind of convenient actually because
i
as well as i'm sure everyone else in the
world did forget about the show before
coming back to the special
and then you realize that you've got
less than one episode's length to see
the entire series finished
i'm pretty sure the studio making the
series forgot the show considering how
long this recap
was and they put it in for their own
sake so they could figure out
every single plot point that they wanted
to royally [ __ ] up before they started
so koito the friend who i the main girl
was trying to save the whole story and
did actually bring back to life at the
end
doesn't have any memories of the eye
she's just a total prick now and doesn't
even give her the light of day to hear
her out at all which would be fine and
all honestly if it were one of those
stories like you know
you have to be happy you saved her even
if she doesn't remember you
that kind of tragic tale where you're
happy but longing at the same time that
would have been all fine
except the special also reveals that the
reason koito killed herself
was because she had a track record as
long as the oxford dictionary for
preying on male
teachers and she convinced
everyone around her that this one art
teacher at their school sexually abused
her
and blackmailed him into trying to
commit suicide with her
which he didn't she was a terrible
person the whole time
there was even an entire subplot where
the cast thought that maybe the art
teacher was actually the villain the
whole time
and manipulated koito into killing
herself but it ends up he's just a
really nice dude who got strung along by
this girl who we ended up
saving and rooting for for no good
reason
there is absolutely no redeeming quality
about the girl koito
who the entire story was revolved around
saving
and then one of the four girls who was
really torn up by her pet getting sent
through this spin cycle by the
flesh-eating monster
who ended the series really pissed off
saying she never should have been
friends with them or started finding the
monsters or whatever
is suddenly all goody-goody once again
like absolutely nothing happened
like they're just having a nice time
with karaoke and even though she shows
reservations about going back to fight
monsters once they throw out the idea
she is still extremely passive like
nothing happened like her little pet
didn't get decapitated and eaten in
front of her
and then she just disappears from the
rest of the episode with barely even a
goodbye right after
she just hops off the train and that's
it she's done
and then after that girl disappears they
introduce a new plotline
yes in the finale of the show they're
introducing a new plotline
where one of the girls is missing mind
you there are 10 minutes left
in this special by this point and
they're pulling out an entirely new
storyline like they've got hermione's
endless bag of tricks
and then in this new plot it's also
revealed that the friend of theirs who's
missing
was always just a robot or something the
whole time
i don't know it's it's this whole
science parallel human explanation that
was
of course poorly done and then even
though they were like besties for the
rest
throughout the entire series the two
girls left just decide nah
not worth it i'm not gonna die for a
robot i'm not going back in there and
getting rocked by that dream creation
again no i'm not doing it
which is fair honestly but suddenly this
is where they draw the line
really they let their pets die fight for
12 episodes
and now that they've got an actual
reason to go in and fight again
save a friend who they know is actually
their friend
and won't come back as some distant
parallel version of their former friend
who hates their guts and preys on
teachers
now they stop and then as you question
this
what we all love to see in the last
three minutes of any finale three
minutes
a nice time skip and so i the main girl
moves away
yay she forgot about everything that
happened immediately after and dismissed
her only friends in her whole life like
they were nothing yay
and as you think she moves on a minute
later episode time
multiple months in showtime she
remembers a conversation she had with
the robot girl a really meaningless one
and just immediately snaps and is now
all for saving and rescuing her again
and this snap would have been fine if
there were no time skip
but the special sets us up to believe
she had moved on and finally made a
better life for herself that wasn't hung
up on the past and then oop
snap decision let's actually make her go
back
and it's actually the exact same format
to how the original series ended too
where she loses hope after her pet gets
killed but then decides to be a warrior
of arrows and fight the nattos the
harbinger of middle school girls in
japan killing themselves
they did the exact same thing with the
finale it makes eye into this indecisive
little brat who can't make up her mind
at all and then she's like oh
i'm back and then the finale ends
the worst finale i've ever seen the
story of the frankenstein creation one
of the best parts of the show
incomplete the conflict resolution for
this girl who no one really cared about
apparently
and complete eyes character development
incomplete enjoyment of
any single character in the show
incomplete
that's it that's all i got to say
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses